Yle Areena.
Kä pyhneet lattiaa.
Minun mielestäni siivoijen kuuluu tiskata ja siivota lattiaa.
Mutta pisket oli jätetty kaikki likasena sinne, ja ne saa nyt sitten olla.
Ja seuraava kerran, kun mä tilan siivoja jollekin ihmiselle,
niin mä sanoin, että nyt täytyy myöskin tiskata ja pyhkiä lattia.
Kiitos ensimmäiselle soittajalle.Nyt totean tutusti, eli tervetuloa mukaan ja matkaan.
Jaksomme on hyvin ruokaisa.
Toki muitakin teemoja on luvassa, mutta syötävät asiat nousevat pintaan, kohon lailla, useaan kertaan.
Tämän puolituntisen ajan mielipiteiden pellolla huhkii Koiviston Lauri.
Eras kansalainen kaipaa sähköpotkulautoihin kilautuskelloa.
Toista taas sen ärsyttää meteorologian vaeltelut televisiossa.
Ja onpa Kekkonenkin taas mukana ohjelmassa.
Nyt suuntaamme aampalapöytään.
Se on huomentapäivää, se on kaivalarattuista, se terve.
Joo, tässä aamupalapöydässä muutaman keppanen jälkeen tässä vaan puodittiin ystäviekkaista sitä, että
nyt tuo hunaja meloni on tämän Suomen markkinoille päätöntä.
Räjestäti ölmänkuulonenkin ole koko hedelmää, että tässä mietittiin, ku maailmaa hedelmiä pullolla,
että miten justiisa tämä kyseinen yksilö pentälle, hunaja meloni on päätötetty markkinoille.
Onhan niitä sitten kaikennäköistä muutakin, ihmeellistä, mitä löytyy ympäri moelmaa,
mutta sitten nimenomaan, että se kyseinen se hunaja meloni on sitten päätöntä,
kyseinen se hunaja meloni on sitten päätöntä,
kyseinen vähän vaan, ja tässä ihmetelti sitä niinku ihan aamupalapöydässä,
kun sattuu olemaan tuota hunaja melonia nii.
Mutta jo, eipä tässä nyt sitten muuta,
oikein mukavaa päiväjatkoa, vaan kaikille kansalaisille,
ja toivotaan jaksamisia ensin viikolla alkamaan uuteen työviikkoon.
Enen puheluita kerron yhden kuuntelijan ideasta.
Hän oli tehnyt tällaista litran jogurtipurkista linnun pöntön.
Kuuntelija kirjoittaa WhatsApp-viestissään näin:
"Höpö, höpö, jogurti tölkiin, linnun pöntön, lentoaukon kokoinen reikä kylkeen viis senttimetriä alalaidasta.
Lusikoi pois, älä irroita, palasta kokonaan, kun jogurti syöty,
vaan painan lusikalla kiekko sisäpuolelle, ei tuu siivoo.
Sahalaitainen pihy veitsit, hyvä tuohon.
Keväällä huuhdeltu tölkki linnun pöntöksi, ylös alaisin, voin lähettää kuvan, kolmen vuoden kokemus.
Näin meille kirjoitti kuuntelija WhatsApp-viestissä.
Hän myös lähetti lupaamaansa kuvan.
Siinä tölkin etureunaan on kiinnitty laudanpätkä, jossa on reikä linnuille.
Pönttö on kiinnitty jonkin röystään alle.
Meille Kansanradioon voi lähteä WhatsApp-viestijä sekä tällaisia tekstikommentteja,
että myös äänimuotoisia, jollaisia on useampi mukana tässäkin ohjelmassa.
Kansanradion WhatsApp-numero on 0445515464.
Numeli täällä hei.
Hei, hei.
Siitä juurttipurkista, mä en tiedä purkista, en osaa sanoa mitä, mutta siitä litran tölkistä, mä osaan sanoa sen verran, että kun se niinkun tuntuu, että se on loppu, ni pistää sen sitten kumolleen jonkun hiponääreen, ja valuttaa sieltä, ja sitten ku sieltä ei enää kipu mitään, ni leikkaa saksilla, siitä särmää kohti niinkun aukisen.
Se on käyttää semmoista niin sanottua nuoliaa.Killä saa kyllä hyvin tarkkaan sen puhtaaksi.
Hienoa, nimenomaan tästä litran purkista oli kyse tässä.
Tämä on minun ratkaisuni siihen asiaan.
Kiitoksia tästä ratkaisusta, ja oikea hyvää sunnotajatkoa.
Kiitos, sanoi teille, kuulemiin.
Hyvää päivää kaikille, ei nopeikaan tällä lappeen ratta tervei.
Tuosta jugurttiasiasta juuri puhustiin, että, miten sen viimeisen pitaraan saatelta ulohtiin.
Kyllähän se on niin, että ei se tarvii millään vedellä huudella.
Po Appel sinne mehulla huuhtelee, ni siitä tulee oikea hyvä jugurtijuoma.
Ei mikää, laimaa jugurti ja kurjuuden makune.
No, että minkälaista Appel sinne me oikette laittaa, nii, toi sitten jokaisen oma valinta.
Sihän en osaa sanoa mitää. Kiitos, hei.
No, se on Tapio täältä, korppoo norskatasta, moi.
Moi, moi.
Kuule, se jugurttipurkki ongelma, niin, eihän siinä oo minkäälaista ongelmaa,
kun näin litran jugurttipurkki ostajana, niin, ku se on pehmeytä pahvia,
ni saksi kylkee siihen keskiosaan, ku se on siellä pystyssä jääkaapissa,
ja kaikki valunut pohjaa, ni siitähän leikataan se puoliksa.
Sitten se siististi raavitaan ylä- ja alaosa ruokalusikalla tyhjäksi.
Se on oikein tarkka kaverini, voi vielä kulmat viimeistellä peitsenkärjelläni,
varmaan tulee tyhjäksi.
No nii, eli sinulla ei ole siinä asia haluut mitään ongelmaa.
Ei, oo ongelmaa.
Kiitoksia, paljon tästä soitosta ja oikein hyvää sunnuta jatkoa.
Kiitos sulle, joo, moi, moi.
No, tää on Airi, koske mökiltä, terve.
Terve, terve.
Määki pistä lusikkani tähän jukurtipurkkiasiaan.
Kun ihmettelen tätä kauhiasta niinku hietänä aikonaan tuntemattomas sotilaiset,
tai mulle ei oo siihen ratkaisu muuta ku tämmönen ratkaisu,
et lopettakaan nyt hyvät ihmiset äkseerääminen tämmösen jukurtipurkin kanssa.
Akko, mä sanoin, et tääl maapallolla on varmaan miljooni ihmisiä, kun ei oo koskaan nähny koko jukurtipurkki.
Niir on kovaa tekoa, et miten ne saa jokapäiväsen leivän ja suuhunsa jotain ruokaa päivittäin.
Mä sanoin, et jos ei ongelmaa oo, ni älkää tehkö ongelmaa, jo kurtipurkin loppuun saattamisesta.
Et mulla on semmoinen olot, ku ihmiselle menee oikein hyvin, ni sitten pitää tehdä tämmöisestä asiasta joku ongelma.
Tähän ei pidä jäädä, vaan pitää mennä eteenpäin.
Pitääs niinku suhteuttaa nämä asiat, et olla Suomessaki vielä kiitolenne, ja pistää oikein käreit ristiä kiittää taivaan isää.
Meil on täällä aika hyvin ihmisellä kuitenkin kaikki asiat, et on sitä ruokaa ja juomaa, jos niinku näin maapallon tasolla tätä asiaa ajattelee.
Kiitoksia paljon, ku soitit kansanradioon ja kerroit tämän.
Kiva, kiitos, heippa.
Nyt on tarjolla kommentteja muihin viimejaksojen aiheisiin, ennen siirtymistä audiomuotoisiin pohdintoihin, niin yksi kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella tullut teksti.
Mariskan myrkynkeittäjästä valittavalle henkilölle voin vain todeta, että 1990-luvulla televisiosta tuli suostu sarja Arto Paasilinnan kirjaan perustujen suloinen myrkynkeittäjä.
Paljon vastaivia murhajuttuja on tullut televisiosta. Pitäis jo kaikki sensuroida kirjoja myöten. Uutistakin, joku voi saada ideoita puukotukseen ynnen muuhun.
Kuuntelija Turust, ja yhdellä Uulla, nimimerkki oli lähettänyt tämän tekstin kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella.
Hei, oli puhe niistä banaanikärpäsistä. Minulla oli banaanikärpäsiä viime kesänä ihan kiusaksi asti, ja sitten talvella minä päätin siirtyä niistä biohajoavista muovipusseista paperipusseihin.
Ja nyt, tänä huona, ei ole yhtään banaanikärpästä näkynyt vielä. Kun on paperipussi, niin se kahvin suodatin pussi on sitten hankaluus.
Mutta minä rupesin kuivattamaan talven aikana lämpöpatterin vieressä sitä suodatin pussia, niin silloin sen pussin kosteus ei rikkonut sitä paperipussia.
Ka heippaa?
Kirsi Vampulasta.
Moni meistä tuntee tällaisia henkilöitä, niinkuin minä, jotka laskeva.
Montako kertaa ihminen sano niinku, niinku, etta tuota, etta tuota.
Nämä henkilöt, ja minä tunnen näitä, eivät kerro tarinoita, eivät soittele yleisön osastoon, esimerkiksi puhelinlangat laulaa.
He eivät myöskään osallistu keskustelun, jos on paljon vähtiä.
Mutta sitten, kun kuulee, kun he kertovat sitä, että se oli kova tarinankertoja, voi hyvänen aika.
Ja mie laskin, se ainakin kymmenen kertaa se sanoi niinku.
Ja kun minä kysytään, no mistä se kertoi?
En mie sitä kuunnella, kun mie kuunteli vain, sepan, että niinku, niinku, niinku.
Normaali ilminen, kun puhuu, normaali asioista, ei se osaa sanoa nii hyvin niitä asioita.
Eli tulee näitä välilausaduksia.
Heippa.
No hei, täältä Sysmatta yks naisihminen soitteli.
Hei, hei.
Yhelle naiselle, joka soitti sinne, että Sysmä tieto on hyväs kunnossa.
Kyl mä olen nyt eri mieltä.
Olen tää Sysmässä asumassa, ja kyllä, tie on eri.
Nuormaista tietää mennään Sysmän keskustaan, ja se on nyt pömpä peltoa, se tie.
Se on paikkaa paikan vieressä, ei se mikään hyväs sellainen oo.
Souko, kynnös pelolajelis?
Se väitti, että Sysmä tieto on kunnossa, vaan ei kyllä eri mieltä.
Oletko sinä häni, joka soitti tässä pari viikkoa sitten, oli ohelmassa?
Joo, olen, olen, sama nainen Sysmä tieto, olen, juu.
Kyl mä oon sitä mieltä, että huonaskunnossa on tie, kyllä, siinä ku se on paikasta paikan vieressä, niistä en tykkää todellakaan jaetta.
Ku ne silloin tästä alustalaito tonne, ku lähetää Sysmää tämän tien alustalaitokuntoon.
Joo, se se voinu se koko mätkänkin laittaa, saman tie.
Näi no.
Ehkä sitten siellä Sysmässä on eri puolilla eri kunnossa olevia teitä.
Voipa.
No, ainakin tää nuoren moisten kautta, ja se on kyllä semmoinen pumppöpelto.
Vois olla paremmassakin kunnossa, että ois kivempi ajella, ku tänne Sysmään olen muuttanut noin 15 vuotta sitten.
Kiitoksia tästä.
Joo, hyvää kesänjatkoa sinne ja Sysmästä ja kaikille tutuille terkkoja, järvelää varsinki, moikka.
Siinä päästiin liikenneteemoihin, samalla aihellaardilla jatketaankin, turva vyötsii skinni.
No täällä, Turusta Anja.
Hyvää päivää.
Ihmettelen kovasti, että tänä aikana, ku on oo sähköpotkulaut, jossa ei tarvii itse potkia ollenkaan, niin musta ne on hyvin vaarallisia, ku nii se ei ollenkaan mitään kilautusta.
Ku sellainen tulee takapäin, niin siinähän voisi siis käytä pahasti kummallekin, jos menee vaikka kääntyy tuonne suojatielle tai jotain, niin eihän se takatulijakaan voi toisee ajatuksia lukea.
Eli jonkinlaista kelloa kaipaat siihen sähköpotkulaut?
Kaikilla pitäis olla ehdottomasti kello, aikanaan ku mä Pielavedellä pääsi oppikoulun isää palkitsemaa heti, osti mulle nuorisopyörä, ja sehän aikaan kaikilla oli pyörissä kello.
Ja kun tuli takapäin noita jalankulkijoita ohittamaan, niin ainaan kilautettiin.
Minkälainen oli nuorisopyörä?
No, se oli vähän pienempi kuin tuota aikuisten pyörä.
Nii, joo, joo, et se oli vain koosta kiinni.
Se oli hoikoostakin, ei mulle siinä ollut muuta mitää erikoista.
Aivan.
Mutta tota just, ni mä oon säikähtäny nii nii monta kertaa, ja oon ollu vaan tuuria, että just silloin en oo vaikka yrittäny ohittaa jotai rapakkoa.
Sellainenki voi olla, että tuota, oon saattanu, ja sitten tuol vaikko asfalttia, ni siellä on tuolosia rapakkoja, ku saatelee.
Niin, ei toi sitten osaa ajatuksia lukea tuoloselta pakkaturella, mutta jos hän kilauttaa, niin silloin en jäti, että sieltä on tulossa sähköpotkulauta tai pyörää.
Kiitoksia paljon, kun toi tämän asian esiin kansaradiossa, ja oikein hyvää sununtajatkoa.
Joo, samoi, moi moi.
Etelä-Pohjanmaalla on semmoinen tilanne, että maataloustukea maksetaan siitä, että nuoriso ajaa verovapaalla polttoaineellä kylällä hurootia ja huvinaan.
Kaatavat nelivetoraktorin pyörillä yliajamalla näitä liikenteen jakajien merkkiä, näitä nuolimerkkiä, sinivalkoisia nuolimerkkiä liikenteen jakajista huvikseen ajavat nuri.
Valtio antaa ajaa tuota huviajoa traktorilla ilman mitään työkoneita perästättä, ei olla menossa mihinkään työhommiin tai tulossa sieltä, ni huviajoa ajetaa, ja kylällä kaadetaan huvikseen näitä liikenteen jakajan merkkiä.
Ei, mikä henkilöautoita kestää ajaa niiden liikenteen jakajan merkkien päältä?
Silloin alla, että ne menee linttaan, painuivat maatavohtenne liikenteen jakajan merkintä, että kyllä pitäis tuohon maatalouteenkin, joku järki saaha.
Se nui hyvin kannattaa, että kannattaa yhteiskunnan pystyttämiä liikennemerkkiä kaataa tuolta maanteilta.
Joo.
Kansanratiossa kerrattiin, että hyviäkin asioita saa soitella, minäpä soitan.
Katkamassa ainakin invataksit ovat olleet tulleet ajalaan, ja on ollut hyvää palvelu vanhalen muorille, kiitos siitä.
Seuraavaksi korviimme saapuu sähköinen puhelutriio.
No, Markku täällä, hei.
Nyt, ku tämän sähkön siirtoyhtiö, Karuna on polttopisteissä, ja taas meinaa vaihtaa omistajaani, googletin tämän Karunan tulokseni.
Karunan liikevoitto oli ollut 52 prosenttia liikevaihdostani.
Tällä perusteella, ku Karuna on monopoli yhtiö, ja ryöstää suomalaisiini, taa Karuna tarvitsi siirtää suomalaisten omistukseen, elikkä valtioon tarvitsi pakkolunastaa tai lunastaa Karuna, ku tämmösiä voittoja kerätää.
Yks konsti olis varmaan, ku joku, ku ne hommat hallitsee, ni tekis kansalaisaloitteen siirtet, Karuna valtioonomistukseen. Et tämmöstä, joo, kiitos vaan, hei.
Ekkonen olisi kääntynyt haudassaan, jos eläisi, silloin jo, kun Suomen sähkön siirto mötiin ulkomaisille, sijoittajille.
Kasitalvesta tulleen Oppositiossa, Torpo huusi kovaan äänen, että välittömästi sähköjen hinta täytyy saada alemmas, jotta kaikilla olisi lämmintä taloilla.
Viime talvena tuli jo varoituksia, tältää käyttäkö sähköä, kuin huomattavasti vähemmän, jotta kaikille riittäisi sähköä.
Ja nyt Karuna menee myyntiin, ja se myydään Espanjaan.
Karunnan hinnat ovat jo nyt järjettämät, suuruusluokkaan suurempi kuin itse sähkön hinta.
Mitään ei ole tapahdullut, mitään ei ilmeisesti tapahdukaan, ja kokoaan ei puutu tähän.
Eli tää kauppa on niinku ihan tästä kivasti vaan eteenpäin, ja katotaas, mikä on sähkön siirtohinta?
Ensi Talvala. Ihan pieni kysymys hallitukselle: aiotteko te tehdä jotain?
Ja oppositiolle: miksi et ole kyseenalaistaneet asiaa? Hei.
Kuten arvata saattaa, niin kohta kuullaan, kommentteja kotimaan politiikkaan liittyen, ennen niitä, yksi kirje vallan eri teemasta, siinä lukee näin.
Se oli joko seitsemänkymmentä tai kahdeksankymmentä luvulla, kun eräässä aikakauslehdessä oli tällainen tieto:
Jos haluat laulejaksi, niin sinun pitää osata laulaa korkeita sekä matalia sävellyksiä.
Jokin ulkomaankielä laulettava kappale myös.
Nyky aikana jotkut laulejat puhuvat lauluissaan, ja joillakin on kähä ääni. Entiset ohjeet saisivat tulla takaisin.
Tällä tavoin lukee kirjeessä, jossa ei ollut mitään nimeä tai nymerkkiä.
Kansanradioon voi lähettää kortteja ja muuta perinteistä postiaosoitteeseen.
Kansanradio PL 79 000 24 Yleisradio.
No, taas täältä Jyväskylä liepeiltä päiviä.
Perussuomalaisten vornainen sai, tai tuomion käräjäoikeudesta, ei hyväksynyt poliisi ja kansanedustoja.
Kaapin päällä oleva valitti hoviin, hovi hylkäs, ei käsitellyt, valitti korkeimpaan oikeuteen, joka palautti sen hovioikeuden, joka palautti sen käräjäoikeuden.
Kukahan maksaa nää viulut, varmaan perussuomalista saa näi hyvän kaverista, joka ei ymmärrä lain päälle yhtään mitää. Kiitos terveisiä, moi.
No, hyvää päivää, kiitos kansanradiosta.
Ihmettelen, ku kukaan ihminen ei ihmettele sitä, että niitä varten kansanedustajan pitää saada sopeutumiseläkettä, kun tavallisen ihmisen pitää sopeutua eläkkeeseen, mitähän on itse niinku kerä. Kiitos.
Kyllä se vain Suomessa on sillä lailla, että, jos on pääministeriksi päässyt, ni, kyllä semmosen äijän pitää pystyä tuotani omaankin pussii, vähän pelaamaan ja laittamaan sitä rahaa, vähän piiloa, nulta suuristijoiden juoksupojaksi, ku alkaa, ja suuristijoiden johtajia, jotka rakentelee Suomeen isoja palatseja, ni, tuotani, kyllä niitten perseitä pitää pääministerin pystyä pitkällä kielellä nuolemaan, tosi syvältää.
Antakaa pääministerille vain lisää mitalia rintaata, oikein äänimöreil.
Täällä ei oo moita mahdollista, kun puhista suomen kansa tyhjäks, nii sanotasi.
Että, nii sanotasi, ne pienetki tuetkin, neki lähtee pois.
Kukahan näitä hoittaa, sillä virkaministeriössä, nii sanotasi.
Sillä taittaa olla vaan niitä, Johnny Jotavi okkoja. Kiitos, ja hei.
Hei, kun pääministeriltä tivataan asiaa, että kuinka nyt on tämä asia, nii mahtaakohan todeta näin, että se tuli minulle ihan pyytämättä. Moi.
Kallumarginaalista, morjesta. Näin se kesäloma toimii, ensin suhmuroidaan, sitten annetaan itselle luottamus huutoäänestyksellä.
Tännöstä, tämä on, hauskaa kätälomaa, hei, hei.
Hei, hei, nyt me vaihdamme sote teemoihin.
No, tässä on Annalisa, päivää.
Päivää, päivää.
Oli, kuule, kertakaikkihan, nii hyvää soittoisi, että yks mies, joka soitti sitä kolesterolilääkkeestä.
Tämmösiä taisi olla enempikin siinä kansanradiossa.
Mutta nyt, minä haluaisin tietää, että miten tämä mies on toiminut, ku se on läikkeyhtiöltä saanut korvaukset, miten siinä toimitaan.
Kiitoksia tästä kysymyksestä.
Mulla on mennyt kaikki lihakset, minä en melkein pysty kävelemään.
Meitä on tuhansia tuomessa, jotka syömme noita kolesterolilääkkeistä.
Ja lihakset tulevat paikakipiäksi, eikä ne, en minä aavistanut, se siitä tulee.
Ei mulla mitään muuta syytä ole.
Niin, se johtuu nimenomaan siitä lääkkeestä.
Niin, nii, kolesterolilääkkeestä.
Se oli hyvä se puhelu, mitä mies kertoi siitä.
Mutta jäi epäseleväksi, että miten siinä toimitaan sitten.
Kiitoksia tästä kysymyksestä ja oikein hyvää suntojatkoa.
Samoin kiitos.
Hei hei.
Syt mä täällä vaan täällä.
Päivää päivää.
Kaikereille, että antitiootti on jo keksity.
Se on inhimillisen titataku, laittaa katedri pishotuvaruksen takia ihnisille.
Hän tätä vaan itsenää nyt onessa terveyskeskuksessa.
Miehille vaan varma paulisinkin.
Ja, ollen tyytä no antitioottia.
Ei tulla kerjaamälläkään.
Tää istitietuvarus on tämmönen juttu, että se voi levitää monolaisiin.
Ja sitten onkin jo totinen paikka, että tulee monolaiset tulerossa.
Tää on hengimeno.
Sama se on johkopotken tuleroksesta.
Se voi aiheuttaa keuhkokuumeen.
Oma verjen tyttö kuoli joukokuumeeseen lääkäriläkon aikana Tampereen keskussairaalassa.
Etä, jos lääkärit eivät vielä tiedä, jos niille ei ole opetettu,
tai jos niitä on kierretty käytämässä antitioottia,
niin alkakaan nyt se prioriteettio.
Ehan toiset täysvät.
Tähän maahan tulee jonkinlainen inhimillinen läkia järjestä siltä.
Mitäs?
Joo, hei.
Hei, hei.
Noi, kuluu semmoinen asiat pelastuslaitoksel ja poliisin ilo eri palkamaksaja.
Ei se sitä silti estä.
Miksei pelastuslaitoksel oll yks poliisi, mikä lähtis ambulanssimukkaa?
Aininko turvaamaa sen ambulanssityöskentelyä.
Tyllä, ja matkaljou vois videoistotaan vastaan tulevat autot,
jos sattuis joku semmoinen.
Ja poliisil ois paljo muutakin hommakon turvaat niit ensihoitajii.
Mitä muuta?
No, hänhän vois alottaa tutkimukset siel jo.
Jos on kolaaripaikka, niin silloin hän vois liikennettä ohjata.
Ja sit, jos on kuolemantapaus, niin siinähän täytyy pöytäkirjat täyttää.
Poliisil ois paljo hommi, ja jollei sil sit on sit, se lähtis ambulanssimukaan takas.
Ja lähtis sit seuraava keikaa.
Et tämmönen, mun mielestä, ku ei se sitä edes, et nii tarvitsis sama firma maksaa palkaa.
Silva, kiitoksia tästä edutuksesta.
No joo, kiitos.
Ei.
Televisioon ja radioon liittyvät ajatukset saavat seuraavaksi vuoron, ennen puheluita yks sähköposti.
Olipa mahtavat jalkapallon MM-kilpailujen TV-selostukset.
Kiitokset selostajille, etenkin Härköselle ja Virkkuselle sekä studion asiantuntijatiimeille.
Saihan, siinä runsaasti valaistusta jalkapallosta.
Varmaan moni, etenkin kesämökillä ja näkövammainen, haluaisi kuunnella niitä radiosta.
Kuitenkin radioselostajat erikseen.
Ei se toimi, jos telkkarissa aletaan kertoa kaikkea yksityiskohtia.
Näin lukee sähköpostissa, jonka meillä oli lähettä nyymerkki, vanha Futisfani.
Kansaradion sähköpostiosoite on kansan.radio@yle.fi.
Hei, pyytäisin selvennystä semmoisen, miksi television meteorologit ykkösellä vaeltavat edestakase siinä ruudussa?
Ei ne ruudussa vaella, vaan siellä studiossa.
Mutta, miksi ne näin tekee? Eiks ni voisi vaan seistää toisesta reunasta?
On niinku pannu ärsytämää, vähäsen tämä asia. Kiitos.
Servehdist, olen erittäin huolestunut sellaisesta asiasta, että tämä ylepuhe on lopetettu.
Ja, koska monet varmasti kaipaavat ylepuhetta, koska kaikki eivät halua kuunnella musiikkia koko aikaa,
niin, niin, monet ilmeisesti kaipaavat tätä ylepuhetta takaisin.
Ja, se on mielestäni aivan ruokotonta ja kauheaa, että ylepuhe on laitettu pois, lopetettu.
Ette, voi voi.
No, täältä pirkammalta jo eräs eläkeläismummo soittaa tästä.
Television tekstitystä on muutettu ihan kaikissa ohjelmissa valkoseksi.
Valkoinen pohja on myöskin siinä taustalla, niin eihän siitä näe mitään.
Mikä siinä on tullut, ettei voi sitä tarkistaa, että miltä se näyttää, se televisioruudun teksti, kun siinä on valkoinen teksti ja valkoinen pohja.
Ei muuta, kiitos, hei.
Terveehdysteltä, tansipirkanmaa, mustikka metsistä.
Alkaa sinistä mariaa olemaan jo ihan mukavasti, ei ehkä ihan paras satokausi, mutta mukavaahan täällä, poimia kuunnella linnujen laulujen.
Kuulokkeista samalla kuuntelee Yle Areenaa, ja nykyään, kun on muodista tämän teet, äärikokemukset ja adrenaliinin tavoitteluni, annan kaikille ilmaisen vinkin, jolla on mahdollisuus Yle Areenaa kuunnella.
Kuuntelin itse ensin Kalle Haatase, erinomaisen ohjelman koskien metafysiikkaa, ja sen jälkeen soittolistalla pyörähti soimaan Kansanradio.
Mentiin kyllä ääripästä toiseen, todella mahtavaa jumppaa aivoille, ja voidaan puhua äärikokemuksesta. Hyvää kesää kaikille.
Marjametsässä pysyimme myös seuraavissa puheluissa, ennen niitä muistutan, että Kansanradion jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan, joka perjantaikolo 21.
Jos merkkaat sydämen kuvasta, ja tilaat ohelmasta ilmoitukset kellon kuvasta, niin saat aina ensimmäinen tiedon, kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
Heikki, täältä askolasta. Terve.
Terve, terve.
Mitä asiaa mä rupesi ihmettelemään, ku just olin mustikassa.
Ja sitten huomasin, kuinka tää poimuri on vaikee puhdistaa, ja siihen pinttyy tää marja, ja kaikki bakteerit herkästi, jos ei kunnolla pesee.
Samaten poiminta-ämpärit, nii hiää likaa, nii, se, että ku nää ulkomaalaiset poimijat, jotka on siellä vähän kehnoissa oloissa, nii, onkos niitten nää poimintavälineet sitten aina siistiä ja hygienisia?
Miten ne saa ne pestyä, ja haluavatko huolehtii siitä? Niishan tulee helposti bakteeria. Tää on mun kysymys, ja ajatus vaan, että.
Missäs tällainen asia tuli mieleen?
No, ihan siitä, ku mä omaa marjanpoimuria putsasin, mustikoita olin poimimassa. Niikö, se, että ku mä aika usein talvella ostaa varsinkin noita pakaste mustikoita, nii, ja moniha ostaa ihan tuoretta, näin kesälläki, torilta ja kaupoista, ni onko se sitten aines hykienistä, siistiä?
Selvä, kiitoksia, paljon tästä pohdinnasta tai kysymyksestä, ja oikeää hyvää kesäpäiväjatkoa.
No, samoin, samoin, parentia kelejä odotellessa.
Kiitoksia.
Oi.
Arvose Erja soittaa keskisuomesta, hei.
Hei, hei.
Selma oon autossa liikkeellä, mutta tuota, niin, kuuletko?
Heikosti kuuluu, mutta kerro vaan.
Ihan sellaisella asialla oon, siis mulle jo mitään valittamista, mut ihmetyistä siitä, että muoriaihmitiä oon nii palja työttömänänen.
Miks ei ne mene tonne marjatiloilla, on todella vaikeeta ollut saaha.
Suomalaisia, nuoria, ei saa esiin edelle matikan poimintaan, tai tuonne paderman poimintaan.
Ja, nyt kun noita syölupia myönnettiin niin vähennäisille ulkomaalaisille, niin teolisuksa ei puu saamaan marjaa riittävästi syksyllä.
Ihan mulla on tuttavilla matikan tiloja, ni ois, että ei pitää, että ei suomalaiset, ei yksinkertaiset muodet, ei halua tulla, vaikka siellä kyllä ymmärrän toki, että se vaat hyvin se sonki luonteinen työ.
Siellä tienää aika hyvin, se on kovaa työtä ja vaatii arkeruuta, että siellä pääsee palkoidetta.
Eli kehotat suomalaisia nuoriaa menemään marjatiloille töihin?
No, esimerkiksi, mä oon 14 kuultiana aloittanut sen huoman, ja 12 kuultiakannut, joka pitää, ja tovaa sillemus maastikkaa ja harkeita pääsee.
Kiitoksia tästä ehdotuksesta ja oikein hyvää kesäpäiväjatkoa ja ajoa sinne.
Hallo, tämä on urilasta, tämmönen ihmelinen juttu, ku tuossa ihmiset kerää hirveästi marjoja itsellensä,
näyttelee kuvia tuolla netissä, simmosta kehumista ja muuta, että vuodesta toisen samat ihmiset kerää satoja litroja varjoja,
antamatta kenellekään yhtään mitään, eikä, siis tota ei myydä, eikä,
Tää kuuluu varmaan tähän pohjamaalaisen ihmisen luonteessa, tämmönen, itselle satoja litroja laatikot on täynnä,
ja tää on tämmönen, ei muuta, tässä, siihen pitäis jo kiinnittää huomiota, kiitoksia, hei.
Pari kesäistä runoa, on ihan pian vuorossa.
Nyt kuitenkin, yksi WhatsApp-viesti siinä lukee näin.
Hei, kansanradion juontajat ja kansanradion sisältöä tuottavat.
Kuuntelimme Yle Areenasta vanhoja kansanradion tallenteita ajomatkan Kilpisherveltä Kaarinaan.
Onneksi on olemassa tällainen foorumi, jossa jokainen saa ilmaista mielipiteensä sen laadusta riippumatta.
Oli mielenkiintoista kuultavaa.
Jatkakaa samaan malliin, mukavaa joulun odotusta, ystävälisin terveisin L et J.
Täällä tavoin luki siis WhatsApp-viestissä, kiitoksia näistä sanoista.
Vielä ennen runoja kerron kansanradion puhelinnumeron, se on 0, 8, 0, 0, 1, 5, 4, 6, 4.
Ja puhelu on soittajalle maksuton, ja muistuksena, että sunnuntaisin kello 12.30 alkaen tuossa numerossa vastaa ihmisvastaaja kolmen tunnin ajan.
Olami soittelee hyvää päivää, luen runoni heinäaikaan, 60 luvulla.
Aamu Usva pellolla leijailee, heinä tuulessa heilimöi, heinäntekoon ihmiset kiirohtaa, heinäaika, taas heinä kuu.
Heinä seipäät oliasti varjoineen, seisoo rivissä, toisiaan tarkkailee.
Pieni sammakko seipään juurella, katsoo silmillään suurilla, katsoo kohti auringonlaskua, kohti iltaa jo hämärtyvää.
Terveisin Olavi.
Hei, mitä sä aalollat se? Sitä odottaa.
Kauniina päivänä usein vietetään, myös pieniä sateita siedetään.
On melkein vuosi saatu odottaa.
Paljon kaivattua kesäroma.
Loma useita piristää.
Heti aletaan hauskaa virittää.
Rakkautta ja muuta mukavaa.
Mistä iloa ja onnellisuutta saa.
Näin loma aika hyvin sujuu.
Joskus kompastuu jujuu.
Loma päin mäntyä menee.
Silloin hankki, soutuu veneen.
Souda outoon paikkaa.
Huonon onnen taittaa.
Tielä ilo irti ottaa.
Onnen saa uudestaan.
Näin se menee.
Kannattaa vaihtaa paikkaa, jos huonosti loma menee.
Eipä, ei.
Vielä ainakin kaivataan perunoita.
Ennen viimeisiä puheluita minä toivotan teille kaikkea hyvää.
Koiviston Lauri kiittää ja kumartaa.
Kansaradio jälleen viikon päästä.
Hälytys, hälytys, alarm, alarm, ihan kauhea uutinen toi.
Vaikka onhan se ollut tiedossa, että kameroita voi olla missä vaan, mut että, kenen kans vaan juttelee tai kuljet, tai kuka vaan sua kattelee jostai kauempani.
Se voi kuvata sua asiaa samalla.
Ja pistää kaiken niinku koko maailman näytille.
No, tietysti semmoinen sääntö, että joo, käyttäydyi sillai tuolla, julkisesti niinku kaikkien haluaisi sut näkevän.
Mut silti, koska nämä tuo sen niinkun jotenkin sitten semmoisiin kahdenkeskisiinkin hetkiin ja kaikkiin.
Ja ei tarvii enää olla piilokamera.
Jos sul o rillit tai aurinkolasit päässä, niin, aloo, miitää maailma on menossa.
Hei, mä oon Uutti, seitsemän ve, ma halusii lisää perunoita Vaasan keskuskoulun.
Ma heippaa, ei mulla muuta.
Oi mieksillä, isä kaikilla, naltitään tästä, iänestä, suves, eikä tehnyt tahatoisellen.